يتساءل الكثير من الآباء والأمهات عن
أطفال صغار جدًا ، وهو ما هو تأثير
الكثير من الأشخاص في كتلة الوجه على
التعلم العاطفي ، أعني أنه إذا لم يتمكنوا من
رؤية التعبيرات لمدة عام الآن أكثر
من عام ،
فسيؤثر ذلك بطريقة ما على ذكائهم العاطفي
أنت تعلم أن هذه هي المرة الأولى
في التاريخ التي يحدث فيها هذا بالفعل ،
لذا لا أعتقد أن العلماء
لديهم الكثير ليقدمه ،
يمكننا فقط التكهن بأنني سأقول
إنك تعلم أن
كل من الأطفال الأكبر سنًا والصغار يتمتعون
بمرونة ملحوظة في
بعض الأحيان  هذه المرونة
هي الاستثناء ولكنها في
الواقع هي القاعدة لذا أعتقد أنك
تعرف ما إذا كان لديك
طفل يبلغ من العمر عامين في المنزل أو يبلغ من العمر ستة أعوام
أو 16 عامًا
بينما يجب أن نعترف بذلك
هناك صعوبات بينما يجب أن
نعترف بأنها كانت صعبة بشكل خاص على
المراهقين
من بعض النواحي أنه ليس من الرائع ألا
تكون قادرًا على رؤية ابتسامات
أو عبوس الناس وأعتقد أنه يجب أن نتوقع
أن يرتد معظم الشباب و
أعتقد أنه من المهم جدًا يا أندرسون أنه عندما نتحدث عنك ، فأنت تعلم العودة إلى أه تعرف الروتين ورؤية الأجداد والعودة لرؤية أصدقائنا شخصيًا أننا لا نفعل ذلك من إطار لك تعرف الخسارة وأنت تعرف الانكسار والثاني أعتقد أنه إذا كنت أه فقط ركزت على السلبيات ، فإن الشباب سوف يستجيبون بطرق تشبه في الواقع أنك لا تعرف أنك متفائل أو تحب ذلك. الطريقة التي يتعامل بها الآباء أو الأشخاص من حول الأطفال بالطريقة التي يتعاملون بها مع الأمر ، سينتهي بها الأمر إلى تصفية كيفية تعامل الأطفال مع الأمر ولا يعني ذلك أننا لا نمر بوقت عصيب حقًا ولا أريد أن يقوم أي شخص بذلك خذ من هذا أن الوالدين يجب أن يكونوا بوليانا أو أن تتجاهل حقيقة أن هناك جائحة عالمي وأكثر من ذلك ، أريد فقط أن أقول ذلك ، نعم ، هذا ليس ما أوصي به ولكني أعتقد أنك تعرف  لامتلاك القدرة
على القول
أنك تعرف على الرغم من ذلك ، أنا فخور حقًا
بهذه الأشياء التي رأيتها ،
هل تعلم في ذلك اليوم كما تعلم ، أنا
متحمس حقًا بشأن هذه الأشياء
التي تحدث لديك
لتعرف حقًا ، ركز على الأشياء
التي تعلمها أطفالك ، أه
أحسنت فعلًا وتريد أيضًا أن تعرف
ركزهم على المستقبل بطريقة
إيجابية ،
وأنت تعلم أن المعلمين الذين
أحترمهم كثيرًا
قد قلقوا قليلاً  الشيء الذي
تعرفه لأن العناوين الرئيسية تتحدث عن
تعلمك للكوارث وتعلم
أن القضايا الخطيرة التي تحتاج بالطبع إلى
اهتمام عاجل
ومع ذلك نتواصل مع
شبابنا بطرق تؤكد أننا
نعتقد أنهم سيحققون نتائج
جيدة وأنهم  أنت تعلم أننا واثقون من
أن العام المقبل سيكون عامًا جيدًا